les trois derniers et les trois premiers
on va d'abord voir le troisième dernier
c'est à dire le celui qui est juste
avant gilles verdez à celui qui avance
gilles verdez venoix non merci c'est bon
celui qui est avant gilles verdez bien
mais tu es ce que vous avez prévu ce
qu'on va voir le classement des trois
premiers voilà l'or est un flop 3 3
isabelle vous êtes troisième
les flops ça veut dire vous êtes
antépénultième isabelle avec je vous le
dis 47% de bonnes réponses
isabelle est ce qu'on peut la voir où il
se situe vous êtes à moins de son label
voilà mais c'est pas grave vous êtes
très bonne d'autre part est ce qu'on va
voir maintenant le top 3 le 3e 2e et le
3e du top 3 avec 3 est troisième
le troisième a rien sur soir s'il vous
plaît
stress les rives et jean michel algay
valérie jean-michel à égalité secours on
va voir maintenant le deuxième du flop
3 le deuxième plus mauvais et on aura
après le dernier stalmans là c'est
benoît dubois benoît dubois benoît
dubois qui est ce qu'on peut voir le
score de benoît dubois 41% bonne réponse
et on va donner d'ailleurs tout de suite
le dernier ça va benoît alors que
britney spears a d'abord j'ai un
personnage donc c est bien sûr le
dernier va le donner tout de suite c'est
doc gynéco avec 29% de bonnes réponses
bravo 10 sur 34 mersey
on va voir où vous vous situez vous
inquiétez ce qui prouve quand même ça
n'a aucun rapport avec l'intelligence se
cuit parce que doc est quand même très
brillant arrive quand on est une bonne
élève
on trouve toujours des circonstances
atténuantes à l'est le deuxième baquet
attention le deuxième le deuxième qui a
le plus gros qi ça se joue entre maxime
ligny et daniel moi je me suis un peu
effondré et oui et daniel moreau restant
peut-être toutes les niches maxime
daigneault deuxième
le bois de réponse vaut maxime très fort
mon chéri et daniel moreau
[Applaudissements]
daniel moreau et c'est pour vous le
dernier cas le plus gros qi d'huître